[Musica]
ciao a tutti buon pomeriggio io sono
paolo sono bambino disubbidiente molto
refrattario alle regole e oggi ne ho
diverse allora volevo raccontarvi della
di quello che mi è accaduto io tanti
anni fa ho cominciato a lavorare con
persone con sindrome di down e ciò che
avevo un giorno amico carissimo escano
lamberto giannini che ha iniziato a fare
laboratorio teatrale con le persone
anche disabili lui dice tutti quanti
abbiamo un corpo tutti quanti abbiamo
un'anima quindi tutti quanti possiamo
essere attori
apro il mio laboratorio a tutti e quindi
analizzata venire tantissimi tantissime
persone di tantissimi tantissimi tipi no
e soprattutto tante persone anche con
disabilità e qualche anno fa io ho detto
vi piacerebbe lavorare con persone down
questo argomento era molto controverso e
non ho detto sei pazzo perché perché ti
vai a
a buttare dentro un circuito strano
perché perché è delicato l'argomento ma
io che sono disubbidiente che sono una
persona controversa ho detto perché no e
ci ho avuto da quel momento grosso
problema cioè io non riesco più a
lavorare con persone non da un lavoro
solo coi da un io vorrei che dove dire
ci fosse una cosa cioè io ho detto ma
veramente perché tutti mi dicono va beh
ma c'è un fratello da awards no no no no
non diciamo
iniziamo a sfatare questo mito che
bisogna per forza occuparsi dei problemi
nella misura in cui ci toccano ed i
problemi ci si può occupare
tranquillamente anche se non ci toccano
direttamente
fatto sta che queste persone down
avevano questo cromosoma che faceva
filtrare meno le emozioni e quindi loro
avevano una confidenza con la felicità
che io molto spesso non avevo e che
tante persone che conoscevo non avevano
quindi io la mattina incontravo tante
persone in town che in realtà erano
veramente cioè come dire quella roba là
poi andavo con persone down ed erano
molto up mi ha detto pensa che paradosso
questa sindrome pensa che cosa strana
non ho questa cosa in realtà a un certo
punto ho puntato una telecamera verso di
loro ho fatto poi un documentario ho
iniziato a fare teatro con loro e uno di
questi ragazzi definiti speciali mi dice
io non ho capito che non ho capito
perché ti occupi tanto di me io sono
normale un ragazzo speciale mi dice io
sono normale ho iniziato a indagare che
cos'è la normalità che cos'è questa
normalità e ho pensato che alla fine le
cose normali sono di una noia mortale
che la vita stessa non è normale la
natura non è normale non è a norma non
esiste un sogno normale non esiste un
amore normale o resiste una persona ne
esiste una famiglia normale
le cose più [ __ ] della vita non sono
normali e questa cosa mi ha entusiasmato
mi entusiasma toe il fatto che le
persone consiglieri da un abbracciassero
molto e non si fa fatica a volte a darci
una mano
ne andò si è amato molto il fatto che
loro hanno questa possibilità di dare
del tu alla vita che a me spesso manca
detto questo sono persone con tu come
con tanti difetti come tutti noi
solo che il teatro in qualche senso
pareggia il teatro non dice siamo tutti
uguali il teatro dice viva dio siamo
tutti diversi e quindi se su una
diversità ci butta un faro ecco che
quella diversità diventa risorsa diventa
un'occasione
e quindi mi sono anche interrogato sul
fatto che le persone down avessero
questa cosa che si chiama molto forte
che è la resilienza cioè la
trasformazione del limite in opportunità
io se posso fare una piccola digressione
ho fatto anche un documentario che si
chiama resilienza che parla della storia
di un figlio di un mio carissimo amico
che si chiama alessandro cavallini che
non c'è più
i miei genitori sono miei carissimi
amici e mi sono interrogato anche sul
fatto che è pazzesco che nel ceppo
indoeuropeo anglosassone mentre se io
perdo un compagno una compagna di vento
vedovo se perdono genitori di vento
orfano non esiste una parola che va da
identificare la condizione di una
persona che perde un figlio
e incredibile un genitore che perde un
figlio cosa diventa rimane forse
genitore quindi in un mondo talmente in
permanente in cui tutto è fugace caduco
la condizione genitoriale è l'unica
condizione che forse non cambia mai
allora mi sono interrogato anche sul
fatto che molto spesso le persone con
sindrome di down per essere up si
trovavano molto meno anche sul tempo
noi in questo momento vediamo molto il
presente e ci interroghiamo molto poco
del futuro stando con loro c'è un senso
del dopo di noi
i genitori di persone down molto spesso
si domandano cosa accadrà quando io non
ci sono più e il futuro per me è un
interrogativo molto affascinante che
sono un grande appassionato del cinema
di fantascienza uno dei miei preferiti
di fantascienza e 2001 odissea nello
spazio di stanley kubrick è un film di
fantascienza che nel titolo a un anno
passato da 18 anni celate mai fatto caso
film di fantascienza per antonomasia
cioè nel titolo un anno passato oppure
un altro film che mi piace molto e 1997
fuga da new york altro film di
fantascienza che nel titolo suona hanno
passato da 22 anni
allora quando nel cinema di fantascienza
iniziano a esserci film coi titoli con
degli anni passati
vuol dire soltanto una cosa vuol dire
che il futuro è ora
il futuro è adesso lo pensava che il
2019 magari ci fossero le macchine
volanti se non ci sono le macchine
volanti perché a qualcuno non conviene
c'è di più c'è questo avessero detto
guarda in tasca potere uno strumento con
cui può fare tutte le foto che poi tutti
video che vuoi puoi fare è poi
assolutamente vedere il tempo può vedere
medico farà politico bancario può
comprare un biglietto rientrerà presto
detto non è possibile invece ce l'hai ce
l'hai
è questo io non so se vi ricordate
qualche anno fa c'erano i ragazzi che
andavano in giro a certo punto andavano
in giro e facevano valevole caravello
bello ma lux preso un numero ma rubare
preso mai preso c'erano delle persone
vedevano i pokémon il giro normalmente
vico più di vedere pokémon nella realtà
cosa vuoi che accade nella realtà che
diventi un pokémon può essere può essere
magari sta succedendo alla tira di
contro che sono sono delle cose che ci
circondano incredibili incredibili cioè
tira di gotto che magari a new york c'è
un cartello che dice guarda il caso dice
anzi in cina i cinesi sono dei
marciapiedi divisi 2 una parte per chi
cammina una parte per chi cammina
guardando il cellulare a new york c'è un
cartello che dice in caso di incendio
non farti selphy perché agiate moriva
facendosi selphy col fuoco altro
cartello che dice guarda per favore per
favore mi raccomando mentre attraversi
la strada non controllare il tuo profilo
facebook
la gente vede quanti laico e a un morto
allora ti rendi conto che angosciante ma
è così esiste questo tipo di realtà io
però credo nel futuro penso che non c'è
un avanguardia tanto soddisfacente
quanto quella dell'umanità
io credo che non esista una ricerca su
google tanto soddisfacente quanto quella
che fa il nostro umore quando cerca la
gioia
non esiste una ricerca su google tanto
soddisfacente quanto quella che fa il
nostro umore quando cerca la gioia
allora credo che a volte quando e contro
una persona generosa o educata la prima
cosa che ti chiedi è dov'è la fregatura
esiste questa cosa strana no
pensa a come futuro un ragazzo che
sull'autobus e si alza e fa sedere una
persona anziana una carezza un gesto
d'amore un nipote che aiuta la nonna ad
attraversare la strada
un abbraccio che non c'è un abbraccio
che non ti aspetti oppure che ne so una
una rapa o un gesto di pace una roba che
abbia a che fare con la bontà quando
dico questa parola crea silenzio perché
il vostro cervello non riconosce più st
parola ci state pensando da quant'è che
non sentite la parola bontà diventata
populista demagogica
noi ci stiamo abituando e pensiamo che
siano normali cose come crisi conflitto
guerra e non diamo più normali parole al
contrario
quindi siccome io mi sono stufato della
gente che si lamenta che polemizza
sempre io vado in giro a parlare di
bontà credo che parlare di bontà sia
realmente controverso oggi e credetemi
io ve l'ho detto sono disubbidiente sono
molto di subiti io mi ricordo quando ero
piccolo la mia mamma si metteva così
sono come è paolo e la mia mamma
è vivace sta frase è viva mi ricordo
quando si andava in giro la mia mamma
dice come a scuola mio figlio la maestra
e professore dicevano sempre la stessa
cosa guardi il suo figlio è intelligente
ma non si applica sempre così allora io
mi ricordo che vissero per raddrizzare
il bimbo vivace lo mandiamo dalle suore
perfetto io mi ricordo primo giorno di
elementari mi ricordo che mutavano
sempre fuori
a me io vivevo fuori praticamente facevo
all'appello allora battocchi pani
mantellassi ruffini fuori querci fuori
io stavo fuori che il primo giorno io
vidi non avevo mai visto il sangue è
vita mia il primo giornata in classe vd
il crocefisso cosa oggettivamente
violenta con gesù con le stigmate calebb
al sangue che usciva dalle mani io
chiese la sua ora perché quel signore mi
guarda e soffre sei anni e mezzo set
la suora che era piccola così sembrava
un pinguino di madagascar e sai carini e
coccolosi carini e coccolosi arriva
verso i casi perché quel signore vi
guarda e soffre la sua ravello dipende
verso di me e mi disse è colpa tua
si è sacrificato per te allora io ho
iniziato e st parola colpa e mi domando
ancora oggi come sarebbe la mia vita
se avessi visto una croce con accanto
gesù sorridente che stava così
mi domando ancora oggi come sarebbe
cambiata la mia vita se quella sua ora
prima di insegnarmi il sacrificio ma
avesse insegnato la misericordia
quando io tornai a casa la mia mamma mi
ha detto come è andata a scuola ha detto
mamma mi ha stupito una cosa che non mi
hanno chiesto come sto
[Musica]
la domanda come stai e una domanda che
fa parte anche del futuro e la domanda
stupenda che presuppone delle risposte
che noi diamo per scontato le risposte
possono essere tutto bene tutto a posto
oppure insomma non ci lamentiamo oppure
bene da e tutto bene
benino oppure anche normale c'è poi
un'altra risposta possibile come stai
sono felice se rispondi sono felice ti
guardano così c'è uno chiede in che
senso
un altro dice boh forse si chiama così
non è concepibile la felicità non è
concepibile
io lo dico soprattutto a voi maschietti
quando vi succede una cosa bella avete
chiuso il contratto vi arrivano dei
soldi quando vi succede una roba bella
c'è sempre la figura femminile accanto a
voi può essere la vostra fidanzata la
vostra compagna la vostra moglie che
quando vi succede una cosa bella vice
sito solo dire a nessuno sa perché
perché la felicità destra sospetto
perché se io sono felice faccio girare
le palle a qualcun altro
e questo qualcun altro ha solo un modo
per farsi girare meno le palle rom per
tele questo andare contro non è
controverso e contro e basta
allora una suora mi ha fatto fare pace
con questo concetto e tanti anni dopo
l'ho ascoltata un'altra suora che ha
detto non invitatemi mai a una
manifestazione contro la guerra ma se
fate una manifestazione a favore della
pace
io sarò in prima fila siamo a madre
teresa di calcutta
allora io mi sono accorto che nel futuro
vorrei andare da un bambino vivace come
me ma non lo butterei fuori io lo terrei
dentro perché bambini vivaci hanno
bisogno soltanto di una cosa di carezze
e so che faticoso
ma i bambini vivaci bisogna fare tante
carezze
e poi gli spiegherei che la sindrome di
app è soltanto una cosa di ricerca è che
non ho ancora capito come si possa fare
a cambiare il mondo però gli direi che
facendone alla carezza in testa
domattina lui si può addormentare si può
svegliare e se quando si sveglia lui ha
provato a migliorare se stesso è già
come se avesse cambiato il mondo
[Musica]
no